alors coup de coeur de benoît qui
concerne ces images on les a vus c'est
vrai que c'est une belle histoire c'est
un conte de fées comme on les aime c'est
un danseur qui a qui a posté une vidéo
de lui faisons michael jackson raconte
les d'actes mans et ben oui alors je
vais vous parler de salif gay dauphin
guèye a posté une vidéo sur les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est un danseur de street
donc voilà il a posté une vidéo
s'étaient relayés par des grandes stars
américaines du coup sa popularité a pris
de l'ampleur
il a même traversé les états unis pour
aller sur le the ellen show donc
l'émission de ellen degeneres a pris la
fin à leur tour hier il était sur danse
avec les stars il est en train
d'exploser sa annonce une grande grande
carrière pour ce jeune âme qu un
incroyable danseurs c'est un accord de
danseurs ils devraient faire d'ailleurs
danse avec les stars
il est habile et il est trop bon pour
eux il est trop bon pour l'instant on a
vu que du michael jackson a effectué sur
instagram il est passé de 9000 abonnés à
1 million 300 livres en quelques jours à
peine regarder cette vidéo c'est vrai
qu'il en sera très bien
concernant la suite moment-ci palois
malheureusement d'en parler vous verrez
qu'il y aura énormément de surprises moi
même je suis le premier surpris
c'est de vous faire découvrir money
d'erreur ainsi qu il a été invité par
allen le talk show américain est vrai
que on l'a appelée on l'a payé un billet
d'avion aller danser chez elle regardez
et ça c'est vraiment ce qu'on appelle le
conte de fées le week end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mardi donc le gars il dansait dans la
rue on l'appelle on lui offre un billet
d'avion il a los angeles et leurs idées
tu reviens parce que maintenant tu fais
de danse avec les stars mais il mérite
ça fait des années que dans les revues
en fait chéri parce qu'en fait il fait
beaucoup de bruit non mais parce que
j'adore but il fait des vidéos dans moi
dans la rue mais il a fait des tas laine
chaude et dans ce conte est vraiment il
est très connu dans le milieu hip hop
salif et à l'instar des twins
mais les barrières parce qu'on peut
laisser voilà il avait pas gagné tout
est magique des réseaux sont exactement
et comme j'avais participé à l'ancienne
à la france a un incroyable talent il
avait perdu il avait été éjecté du
programme ils avaient été récupérés
après par beyoncé ça leur a fait une
carrière extraordinaire ils font des
trucs pour des grandes marques
américaines et où donc salif je pense
que c'est le même destin qui l'attend et
c'est magique
et hier soir donc la cop sucker
consécration de consécration il était
dans danse avec les stars
[Applaudissements]
je
mis au placard noir
[Applaudissements]
un cadeau
plateau
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
on va bien évidemment tout à l'heure sur
danse avec les stars ce sera d'ailleurs
le quart d'heure sans filtre magali un
candidat comme ça après raison à la vue
les dollars qu'elle s'était laissé longo
picsou son avenir est tracé bien oui à
ce moment- moi et je le prends tout de
suite ça mais je crois qu il est bien
loti moment parce que c'est hollywood
c'est pas magali la voit jamais
voilà maintenant je suis fan de ce genre
de vie et franchement moi les réseaux
sociaux peuvent changer une vraie vie
qui l'avait bien compris chez des potes
parce que là ya même quelques on domine
pas du tout que les marques dont on
parle il a un bandeau 1 dames
ça se passe bien jean marc vous n'avez
plus votre chauffeur de salle vous lui
avez mis une perruque et c'est bien le
même sens barre alors moi j'espère ça va
pas casser sa fraîcheur quand même si
moi j'ai toujours s'en foutent
c'est ce que j'allais bien je crois que
eric a trouvé son petit frère de danse
je crois qu'il pourrait former un duo
avec lui les bombes à un mouvement
magali dans le dans vos sens aussi à ces
familles par mois alors minimum vingt
mille euros par mois si vous nous
regardez vous avez des propositions de
salaires à 20000 euros en plus par
magali garde à vous signez à lui acheter
lorsque des états unis c'est magnifique
ça
[Applaudissements]